de forma sorpresiva y de madrugada
Israel bombardeó la franja de gaza
matando a diez civiles y a tres
cabecillas de la yijat islámica
Palestina un ataque bautizado como
escudo y flecha que podría derivar en
otro gran enfrentamiento entre estos
líderes había un alto Rango del Consejo
militar de la yihad un coordinador de la
facción en cisjordania y el comandante
en el norte de gaza que sucedía a otro
comandante muerto en los ataques
israelíes de agosto del año pasado junto
a ellos cómo confirmó el grupo también
murieron las esposas y algunos hijos
Menores en total entre las víctimas hay
al menos cuatro niños y cuatro mujeres
una veintena de heridos e incluso la
prensa Palestina reportó el deceso de un
conocido médico subesposa y su hijo
pequeño las fuerzas israelíes que no se
han pronunciado sobre estas víctimas
detallaron que para la operación usaron
40 aviones y drones que Asimismo
destruyeron 10 instalaciones de la yihad
islámica unas acciones que han recibido
ya la condena de Jordania la autoridad
Palestina y mientras las milicias
palestinas han prometido que Israel
pagará el precio aunque aún no han
definido como y tampoco está claro si se
va a involucrar el grupo jamás Y es que
este ataque les pilló desprevenidos pero
también dentro del gobierno israelí ya
que según medios locales el Primer
Ministro Benjamín netanyahu y el
ministro de defensa Joe galán lo habían
definido todo en secreto pese haberse
quedado al margen el ministro de
seguridad el extremista itamar benhibir
celebró la ofensiva y a raíz de esta su
partido ha puesto fin al boicot en el
gobierno y el parlamento que había
iniciado tras considerar débil la
respuesta israelí encaza la semana
pasada frente al probable lanzamiento de
cohetes desde la franja que podría ser
inmediato incluso la próxima semana
Israel ha declarado zona de emergencia
los 40 kilómetros que rodean caza y no
descarta que un intercambio de fuego se
extienda por varios días